i want you to take a look at eric i mean  he's just grooving to some tunes there  that he's got on  and this is this is the streamer look  here that we have you know you're  listening to music you're playing a fast  format chess you're enjoying life  but yeah you would be so annoyed if this  was otp chess and your opponent was just  dancing away to something  yeah definitely i would i would take it  as a personal insult i mean it just just  unheard of you know it's it's impossible  to imagine but of course this is a  completely different set you have it  with the computers with the screens  between the players and this whole  atmosphere and if already you have a  headphone on uh on then it's very  logical yeah that you if you are  listening to music then you want to get  some energy out of it otherwise  otherwise it would be probably  distracting you yeah so you should  actually enjoy it in order to get the  benefit